rated M for Mature  list of things that my killas keeps  getting longer rax Skaggs bandits  dehydration heat stroke regular stroke  stroke stroke I've never felt so alive  I know that sounds weird but I just saw  handsome jack yeah I know you're here oh  you're my biggest bad blah blah blah  these peoples can't possibly be hoping  that map could lead us to her fault  we're not leaving until we know exactly  where it's telling us to go enhance  image and hands please stop why is  Hyperion China unless don't you work for  this time I'll file a complaint with HR  when we get back it seems like there's  some bad man looking for you to your for  not other dude who has people shoot him  in the chest with fun I'm usually drunk  you can't even begin to understand my  intentions you think I have an aunt  Amelia sacrifices I brought order to  this piss hole of a planet too many  people died that's what people